you know what I'm not going to live in
fear I'm done with it I think a big part
of what happened with Co was people were
afraid and that were you afraid last
time part of me was like What if this
turns into I'm not even letting my mind
go there this time like I'm right wash
your hands stay healthy be your best
self that that it I was afraid for about
15 seconds and then I I smelled
early on yeah man it's I mean letting
letting letting like a a scientific
technocracy guide the world is like I'm
not you got a stinky bro on your mic hey
stink bug oh what's happening dude
what's he doing here you got to you got
I think Carry's white lung
dude be careful well hold on those stink
bugs are from China yeah for real
they're a marmorated they like an
invasive species in the '90s talk about
was that intentional did they well they
apparently they arrived in uh 1996 and
Pa I did all this research was like
where do these come from and how do I
get rid of them and those Lantern flies
aren't those from China too probably